when kids come our way to tell us they
are upset
overwhelmingly all they want and all
they need is for us to listen and be
empathic if one of my daughters is
telling me she's upset about something
I'll picture she's a reporter and I'm
her editor and she's reading me the
article of her distress and that when
she gets to the end of the article I
just have to produce the headline like I
have to have listened so intently that I
can distill it and summarize it and add
nothing and give it back to her that is
overwhelmingly what teenagers are
looking for
and so often what they get instead is
advice curiosity plus empathy or just
empathy is I would say overwhelmingly
the most effective and also wanted
response when teenagers come our way
with their distress